okay all right well glad to be with you
this morning
uh we got a lot of topics to cover today
uh i have um first we gotta cover the
netflix the this movie that came out
apparently cuties
with netflix that's creating a lot of
havoc tic tac
where apparently microsoft was supposed
to be winning it's no longer microsoft
oracle came out of nowhere we're getting
ls there's echo echo echo echo echo echo
yeah yeah yeah
that's why it's already been fixed right
now okay let us know if the echo has
been fixed
thumbs up if the echo has been fixed
just let us know if the echo has been
fixed
batik or they're still hearing an echo
just let us know if there's no echo
that's better
it's a big like 10 second delay too so
all right let's see it's fine now okay
thank you awesome
results okay all right so we got a lot
of things to talk about today tic toc
cuties uh netflix amazon hiring a
hundred thousand new people
apple's iphone launch whether it's gonna
happen or not opec is weaker at 60.
delta uses frequent flyer mile program
to raise six and a half
billion dollars what a way to raise
money nvidia's softbank deal 40 billion
dollar acquisition from uh uh uh
of arm and then two sheriff's shot point
blank execution style in california
compton i believe
there's some controversy there's seven
states where you can start early voting
bloomberg committing a hundred million
dollars
just in florida to help biden win it all
and then uh some fires in la beverly
hills republicans i don't know if you
saw the fires in la is pretty intense
what's going on there
trump's rally speech in nevada buffett
campaigned
for obama and clinton but hasn't donated
or spoken out
for biden and no one knows why and then
brady lost rogue in a four-hour debate
a bunch of other things singapore's no
destination flights to nowhere
and then navid afghari executed in iran
which will
cover that as well but i think we start
off with bloomberg's hundred million
dollars
huh deciding to help his brother joe
biden
win the state of florida
okay here's what this reminds me of did
you watch the last season of curb your
enthusiasm larry david show on hbo
so larry david he goes mocha joe's a
character yeah okay
a reappearing character so mocha joe has
a coffee shop larry david goes in there
the coffee's cold the scone is too hard
the table's wobbly he's upset about it
so he opens a store
right next to it and calls it his spite
store opens a coffee shop right next to
it to put it out of business i think
this is all
like 500 personal with bloomberg all
right he's writing this check
it'll probably be personal towards trump
yes and his hatred towards trump
this is all something happened with
these guys when he was the mayor because
think of the amount of money the fortune
that he is going to spend on his
losing primary campaign and then if this
hundred million
doesn't help him out it's a spite store
on the political side of things
and it's 100 percent personal what do
you think about that adam well obviously
he doesn't like trump i mean obviously i
mean that's
obviously yeah i mean you're spending a
hundred million dollars
but i'm saying the only reason is it's
personal oh
okay no i mean there's obviously more to
it you know i'm going to give you an
answer you're probably not expecting out
of a young adam sas over here let's hear
it um
well most you know from miami florida
boy lived everywhere in florida
florida is literally the most important
state when it comes to elections
agree or disagree yes purple yes it's
purple it has the most electoral
uh college voters al gore bush
controversies
chad's always you got north florida and
more gop
you got south florida more democratic
you got the cubans you got old people
you got haitians you got blacks
it is the most important state so that's
why we're gonna single out this state
but here's my thoughts on this i
actually
hate seeing stories like this whether
it's on the left or whether it's on the
right
bloomberg donates a hundred million
dollars george soros donates
you know a billion dollars the koch
brothers donate
it's just a pay-for-play thing these
super pacs these
one thing for sure is if you're a
billionaire you can just buy your
elections hey
bloomberg wants to give a hundred
million dollars to florida cool
the koch brothers want to give you know
50 billion dollars to nebraska
cool yeah it's just so excessive
and all these billionaires so you're
heartbroken i'm heartbroken unless the
binance
[Music]
i mean it says it right here he's going
to use it
for two reasons number one to obviously
prop up biden but number two
to make trump spend more of his campaign
chest so
you know it's like literally prop him up
yeah he's got i mean he's gonna here's
the windows
question i got for you here's a question
i got for you so so he's gonna spend a
hundred million dollars which first of
all a hundred million dollars is
nothing to a guy worth 65 billion
dollars that's like you having
sixty five thousand dollars and giving a
hundred dollars to a person running for
office that's like you having six
hundred fifty thousand dollars
given a thousand dollars to him it's not
a big deal
and then let's look at how much money
this guy spent on his own campaign yeah
okay
he spent a losing campaign do you know
how much money he spent do you know that
500 million
900 million dollars he spent on his own
campaign and he got 58 delegates
and he lasted less than barely i was
going to say i was going to say not even
a couple
but this is the point i'm trying to make
to you if i'm even gonna ask you crazier
questions
okay say he spent 64 billion dollars
okay in the state of florida say
bloomberg hates trump
so much he gives his 65 billion dollars
to help biden get elected do you think
biden's still going to get elected if he
gives him 65 no there's no guarantee
what i'm trying to say to you is the
following
as much as money matters as much as
money matters as much as you can go out
there and say well it's about this and
it's about that and it's about this
america voted obama when obama was
coming up hillary had all the money
not obama okay when he was coming up
hillary had the money he didn't have the
money
when trump was coming up jeb bush had
all the money jeb bush day one had 140
million dollars
trump had nothing right trump just had a
social media presence
this is more than just giving money i
think what's starting to happen today is
money matters don't get me wrong you
need the super pacs you need the money
100 but if you are not coming out just
yesterday
trump did a rally in nevada right and
just yesterday
look at what trump's doing so yesterday
trump is in nevada
does a rally does it give us a talk i
don't think if it's yes maybe it was a
day before then when he gave the talk
two days ago
he gives a talk in nevada on fire this
guy
lit up right getting up there talking
people hollering
there's 80 000 people when i was
watching it when it was alive
i was in the bathroom i'm being serious
with you
i get out of the bathroom i said babe
look how many people watching i said
there's 80 000 people watching
trump in their bathroom stall right now
listen to this guy speak
from anywhere i said when hillary and
trump are running here's what was
happening if you remember this
hitler's run against trump every day you
turn on facebook
trump was somewhere doing a rally every
day you turned on facebook you didn't
see hillary clinton do rallies
no matter how much money is spent if
biden's strategy is to lock him up don't
have them come out don't let anybody see
him no one's gonna get any opinions any
of that stuff's not gonna take place
i don't care how much bloomberg spends
nothing's gonna happen you know why do
you think bloomberg is such a
lightweight and so
unsuccessful nationally i mean he was i
mean the media company he built is
unbelievable when you look at bloomberg
and
and what that value is of that company
and he was such a great mayor yeah i
mean
you would almost think that he would
transfer over and be an outstanding
president but he's such a lightweight
i mean what is it with him nationally
people just don't identify with him
different strokes for different folks
you have a jewish billionaire who you
know made his money in new york city
he's going to resonate in new york he's
not going to resonate in but he was sick
he did a good job i just thought he
could do a better job in these primaries
and
and you would look at him and have a
little more respect for him but he's
kind of a putts when you think about him
i'll give you a perfect idea there it's
a very good question you point out by
the way very good question we're not
prepared for this that's a very good
question
i will tell you this so you know how you
know how you decide to go away
and come back and reappear in the media
okay like reinvent yourself yeah no
not even reinvent you kind of like when
you have the money sometimes you're
getting all the attention all this other
stuff
you get to a point where you don't want
any attention right because sometimes
you don't want attention because
you don't want your personal life yeah
put your target on your back like how
many times you see jordan doing an
interview honestly never
how often do you see michael jordan do
an interview not even as the owner he
doesn't do it what was the most common
thing when jordan was in chicago and
they would ask him about his personal
life what would michael say to the unit
like people like you what would he say
he would deflect aaa you probably
wouldn't even ask him that question
because you know it's pretty much but if
you
did it was a code in chicago you don't
ask michael about his personal life
but if you did michael point-blank will
look at you and he would say
you know i'm here to talk about
basketball my personal life said it
i don't want to talk about it but my
basketball life whatever questions we
got we can talk about it
so he deflected why some of these guys
just don't want your personal life to be
advertised right so bloomberg
is so big in new york he's the mayor all
this other stuff
then maybe his marriage didn't work out
he's a single guy he's got the money
he's got girlfriends on the side i don't
want publicity
then he decides to go out and get on
social media which i'll tell you how
many followers he has on social media
and this stuff matters today it didn't
matter 40 years ago but it matters today
watch this
bloomberg on instagram has
468 000 followers let me say this one
more time adam
bloomberg on instagram has 468 000
followers
that is less than many 12 year olds that
are putting cat videos on instagram he's
not even
and he's running for office his last
video he posted this morning
got 2 583 views in two hours
with 19 comments and this guy's worth 65
billion dollars
what this tells you for for this for
right here
is the big screen he is not fit for the
big screen
he's fit for the boardroom it's a very
big difference today's presidential to
win
you got to belong here he doesn't belong
there not bloomberg that's my opinion i
wonder how many of those posts he does
on his own do you think he
that's the beauty of trump and some of
these other people you can tell this
bloomberg
he's a twitter finger filter right and
it's a real message that's getting out
yeah i mean look like you said some
something must have happened in new york
and you know
would you be surprised that trump has
bloomberg i mean
how long is the list of people that
trump is pissed off can we add just
bloomberg to that list it's not like
it's a big deal
and depends how thin your skin is
because at some point trump's going to
say something about you so do you hold a
grudge yeah you take it that personally
yeah
he's not he's not cool with that so
apparently that that's not something
he's uh comfortable with but
we'll see what's gonna happen with that
hundred million dollars so apple
apparently
is is not launching for the first time
ever
apple will be doing their event today at
ten o'clock
okay pacific standard time which is one
o'clock eastern standard time
but rumor has it they're they're
launching a new ipad they're launching a
new watch they're launching all this
other stuff
but rumor has it they are not launching
a new iphone
iphone has reportedly been delayed till
october due to covet 19.
do you think that's an accurate rumor
and if it is do you think that's a good
strategy to delay the uh
uh the phone launch till october well my
first reaction is
as good as apple is with marketing with
pr maybe they have a surprise that
they've kept
under wraps and maybe they'll have a
huge announcement about two new phones
today nothing would surprise me
um i guess logically it seems covid
you know in china where they make the
phones might have some sort of impact on
production
but apple's also the type of company
that i don't think they they use too
many things as excuses and they're gonna
find a way to
to use this publicity stunt today to
make some sort of big announcement i
can't believe they'd be
you know kind of go quiet or not have
something big to say
adam just from as a consumer what's the
difference if they bring out a
new phone in september or october now
let me ask you this are you a die-hard
apple fan
no that's the problem yeah to a die-hard
do i have apple yeah
am i like oh my god the new phone like
no well you know to to the die-hard
apple fans
september is like december 24th you know
what christmas means to you yes is what
september means
yeah they want to go line up outside the
stores even though the stores are closed
that's the point
every time that i see i'm in the m i
remember just being in the mall yeah
literally last year and lines out the
door and apple and i and i
you know me i'm a pretty inquisitive
person i'll go you're gonna say go ahead
i was gonna ask while you're saying this
i wanna ask the audience a question
let me ask you how many of you the
moment the new iphone comes out you go
out there and buy it and how many of you
are watching this right now
be honest i tell you myself my answer
i'll tell you right after you tell yours
how many of you the moment iphone 12
comes out you're gonna go buy it comment
below go ahead adam yeah that's
that was actually my point is that there
was lines out the door
and i'm not a die hard really anything
like
oh like i remember just asking people
online like hey
guys what's up what's going on here dude
it's a new iphone 11 it's coming out
i'm like why do you have to go opening
day
man i just love apple i'm like you can't
wait
a day or two nah man i gotta have it
yeah
okay what i wanted to ask that person
was like
how in debt are you what's your debt
situation but don't you want to ask
everybody that questions it's like why
do you like dude
you don't need to run out and get the
new phone the day it comes out
like well that that's the brand i guess
the biggest question is
how often do you really need a new phone
do you need it
every single time it comes out the app
can you use a phone for a year or two
like that's the bigger question first of
all you're talking about a trillion
dollar company
this trillion dollar company's number
one selling product is what
the iphone the smartphone and this
trillion dollar company historically
when you go back to the 80s and 90s you
know what they were known for
selling expensive computers right if you
owned apple you were
rich it was not the 486 or 386 if you
remember the old 386 and a 486
apple was 2 900 bucks 3 500 bucks and
the other computers were 1800
here's the other part when i think about
this data here with uh why by the way
just so you know most people here are
saying
no no way when i say most people
kai would you agree 90 of people are
saying no
90 percent of people are saying they
don't go line up to buy the iphone
9 well good i'm happy to hear right
android android older thing though
because people used to do it back in the
day like if we ask
how many have ever gone to line up and
that's a different quote but that's a
different question but then the question
becomes they're still selling though
like they are still selling because now
people can order online back in
okay i got it you didn't order like you
couldn't order all your money
either you line up right away or you get
it well maybe the better question is are
how many of you guys are going to order
it regardless whether it's face-to-face
or
online you're gonna order it here's
here's a couple things there's two ways
to look into this the way the way i see
this number one
you know apple has a surprise up their
sleeve because they've historically been
known as the surprise like you were
saying earlier
but the surprise was more a steve jobs
not a tim cook thing so i don't think
tim cook is a surprise guy as much as
steve jobs was the other part was well
my book was coming out with simon
schuster so i'm going to shoot
an emergency call with me in june i
believe i don't know when it was it was
a june kai that we had that call
they had a call with me in june and they
said patrick i don't think we can launch
the book on june 18th
i said why is that printers we just
can't print the books the way we did so
we can print
but we're only going to be able to print
5000 and our first batch was supposed to
be
25 35 000. so maybe apple is having a
hard time being able to produce the
phones because if all of a sudden they
got
sure a million orders how the hell are
we going to make it and shipping them
you know it could be
these die hard apple fans are like die
hard comic book fans or something they
expect something
on that date and everybody thinks of
apple as the most innovative company in
the world so
i think they'd miss a big opportunity
today if they came out flat and didn't
have
something that they had to say i use
apple i love apple i don't care about
the new phone it's just another thing
i'd have to learn
i think it's a 10. 10x or something i
got the 6s
it's great it's the apple flip phone
10 10 i think yeah what is this or is
this an 11 is this the 11 so i haven't
so the question is this pat yes are you
basically alluding to
the day it comes out pat's got to get
the news yeah it comes out on buying one
you're getting one
absolutely the day comes and i'm buying
an iphone all right now why
why is this yeah i support the brand
that's it
i don't care what the product is i
support the bro now would the when
would the let's let's take you back a
little bit would the young
hustler entrepreneur 23 year old
okay absolutely tell me why not one he
didn't have money he didn't have money
that's number one number two
all i needed was a phone and a texting
uh method for me to
drive whatever i need to to whoever it
is today
we have multiple media stuff that we're
doing i need whatever that's going to be
the fastest to be able to allow me to do
other things because i got so many
different things so every time
this the processor gets faster i'm i'm
banking on a newer processor so it's a
little bit more technical with my
here's my point yeah 41 year old
stud ceo entrepreneur
sure worth millions go get the new
apple no question the 23 year old
23 year old out there watching this who
has student loan debt and is struggling
to make income
or maybe you're just you know a normal
person or even if you're doing well
i'm not just relegating just people who
are not doing well you don't have to run
out and get the new iphone if you're not
a social media
content creator ceo take a take a couple
months take a year
i think right what's your old phone
isn't what's the right thing to do
with apple it's never what the right
thing to do is it's what the cut like
following is going to do
cult well it's emotional with apple and
that's the connection
for me it's all function like if i'm on
a non-apple device
i am i'm wasting 50 of my time because
it's just slower i don't know how to use
it
it's frustrating yeah so for me it's
it's pure for you a blackberry guy
yeah i did used to like the blackberry
just because you know you could send
emails and text and you know man
if you're a communicator yes i remember
one time i got to a store about
blackberry so remember next blackberry
yeah the walkie-talkie
blackberry oh yeah so one day at the
chinese theater uh
exorcist comes out the movie okay i
don't know if you guys remember the
exorcism like the original
way back you don't remember when they
brought it back in like chinese theater
so they brought it
original exorcist was like in 1980 yeah
1980s so
my i go to my dad i said dad there's
this movie coming out called the
exorcist
what do you think about it my dad says
don't don't screw on watching this movie
i said why is that he's i'm telling you
don't go watch this movie i said dad
my dad never says don't go watch a movie
but he so happens to tell me don't go
watch this movie
exorcist i said what's up with the
exercise well
back in the early 80s i went to uk to
do a certain training for max factor
because my dad's a chemist so he makes
makeup so
i went to uk for a max factor training
he says one day i'm staying at the hotel
and i said look let me go watch a movie
i asked the front desk clerk i said look
what's a good movie to watch
they said there's a new movie that came
out and farsi they call it jangeer
it's the name of it so he says you know
exorcist came out so he says okay no
problem so he goes across the street
across the park to watch his movies he
says i go to the theater
he said no one's in the theater i'm by
myself watch an exorcist
he says i sit there watch this x i'm
like what the hell did i do watching
this movie so he says on my way back to
the hotel i had to cross the street
of a park he said i see this park the
only way i can get to the hotel is i
gotta run through the park is
pat i start running running all of a
sudden i see this couple that are making
out
they see me i thought it was the
exorcist ice cream they scream so
finally i get to the hotel long story
short i go straight to the bar he says
give me two shots of double tequila i
said i take two shots i went upstairs i
left the lights on to go to sleep all i
thought about was the movie
so now this story comes back to me yeah
so a friend of mine
says uh uh uh you know uh we're gonna go
watch the exercises there's two parts of
the story
so i go and i so you didn't listen to
your dad no of course not of course not
so
so i go watch it first while my friend
fernando lasso who lives in ecuador
right now shout out to fernando lawson
one of my groomsmen by the way
fernando fernando lasso conejo
means rabbit right that's what his
nickname what's going on so i go watch
this
with our buddy conejo and conejo says
before we watch
the exorcist we have to listen to this
recording i said what's this recording
this is a die-hard christian guy
fernando lasso
he says this is how when i was in
ecuador going to school this is how
people who worship the devil this is the
kind of music they listen to bro turn
this crap off
he says no but just dunk how crazy it is
i don't need to listen to this stuff
he puts it in for 15 seconds i listen to
it they're reading the bible backwards
that's how creepy this thing is
i said what is the matter with you says
we have to get in the mood before we
watch this movie
we have to get in the mood before i said
you are absolutely crazy so we go sit in
and watch the movie
it's myself a guy named mauricio and
fernando la so so we watch it
we leave first of all the movie was out
of control terrible but one of my
friends
was scared no no no that's scary so my
friend saul lopez goes to watch the
movie and i know he's going to go and i
ask all my friends what time is he going
to the movie
so i go into the movie theater just to
see him i know where he see there's no
clump right there
i grabbed the next walkie-talkie i see
where he's sitting i see
so low
let me tell you what happened with
saul's soul jumps up
i see though i wish we had camera back
then to see the reaction he
jumps up that night he knew i'm in the
parking lot he comes in
he says there's no way i'm sleeping
alone that night true story that night
four of us
slept at my sister's apartment on the
floor
saul if you're listening to this and
watching this you know i'm telling the
truth
you know i'm telling the truth but
that's the exorcist story i don't know
how the hell we got to the exercise well
because you couldn't have done that
on an iphone right using that blackberry
device
if i had an iphone i would have seen the
reviews and i would have never seen the
exorcist but it is what it is oh that's
the whole thing with the blackberry the
walkie-talkie
yeah exactly which was pretty cool i'm
getting a little sign here with the
exorcist and your dad start with the
exorcist
isn't your phone ring the one so you
know that's so crazy
well last night my son finally made me
change it
he finally ironically enough ironically
so but we haven't even spoken about it
can you send me a text right now this is
what i had to change it to because my
son said that i can't stand listening to
the thing scares me tico
tico doesn't like scary it wasn't uh one
two freddy's coming for you that's my
ringtone okay
but now let's change it's classic little
uplifting the animals
house of the rising sun out of the
rising sun so he was he was
a little disturbed why'd you select that
i'm a crazy fan of house of the rising
sun
and you know that's specific don't let
me be misunderstood the animals i mean
they were legit by the way a lot of
great movies have played that song the
house of rising sun
there is a house
so it's a great story yes okay thank god
this is in a karaoke show okay of all
of all time yeah i mean fail of all days
of all times
last night your son tico said enough
enough with the
yeah here on elm street i got a text
from mario
tico sitting right next to me we're
having a conversation and he says daddy
you got to change that ring tonight
i changed it yesterday because for the
longest time we had nightmare on elm
street anyways
uh by the way uh we got to give a shout
out to freddy krueger i mean he's got to
get it he has scared a living crap out
of many kids
do you remember the first do you
remember the first time you watched
knight maranaos well yes and i think
movies were 10 times more scary in the
80s i mean they just were i mean
they just i don't know why is it because
you were we were kids or is it because
they were scary
i think because we lived in or i grew up
in a rural environment so
after you see the movie it's all dark
and cornfields and stuff you think
freddy krueger
and children of the corner are actually
there and there was fewer distractions
you can't get on your cell phone in on
social media and distract yourself right
after that movie
or calm yourself down so i don't know
but they were freaky back then although
i
i hate scary movies in general i don't
even watch them hate them all i
almost want to tell a story about
nightmare on elm street but i don't want
to tell it it's
it's that bad but maybe you guys should
tell this story
it's a pretty bad story by the way was
uh okay let me tell this rabbit
this is a crazy story let me ask the
audience do you want to hear another
crazy story i should almost not tell
this story but guys do you want to hear
the story
threatening not to tell the story we'll
come back to it i don't know
i think we're on topic right now i think
this is the time all right let me tell
you the story so here's what happened
okay it's crazy i mean i don't want to
tell i don't know okay i'll tell you
something
okay okay let me let me let me tell you
what happens the only thing i'm thinking
about is people going to say what the
hell does this guy do here so
so if i go to a hotel room i want to go
to sleep
okay there's nothing worse than a
neighbor
that's blasting music at two o'clock in
the morning okay so i'm on a business
trip
and there's these two people you know
that are next to me blasting their music
and when i go on business trip i'd warm
up with mario mari and i uh get a room
together i always have a roommate when i
go on trips right so i noticed they're
not stopping it
they're not stopping it they're not
stopping and i said look we call
downstairs
we say hey our neighbors are playing
music they call them
they slow down they blasted it again i
said no problem i have the solution on
how to turn off the music you know what
i do
i get the soundtrack song of nightmare
on elm street or those are
the doors are attached i put the phone
under the door
you know the doors are attached of
course and it goes one
two freddie's coming forward and then
the sound of a girl comes out
i see you i see you i'm coming inside
your door
do you want to play with me you want to
play with me you see that one i've told
you
so next thing you know you see these
girls screaming
they totally start they come outside
they're knocking on everybody's door
everybody's door they're knocking on
someone's in here you know what they did
they left and we went to scared of that
very simple thing
thank you thanks to nightmare
on elm street and freddy krueger he was
people are saying you've told this story
pat
if i have told this story you were
pranking that to overshadow what they
were playing too
no question about it yeah okay so let's
get into a couple other things my guy jj
goes what the hell is pat on about right
now
you on a twisted little vibe guys just
rolling but there's a lot of stories
there's a lot of stories that you you do
not know about this guy here so
all right which one do you want to get
into two share of shot point blank
execution style in california disturbing
new video shows a 31 year old deputy
tending
to her partner who's 24 years old as she
hides
them both from uh uh behind a column
after a man fires a gun at the 2la
county sheriff deputies sitting in their
patrol cruiser saturday night in compton
reward money now 175 000 los angeles
mayor
eric garcetti on sunday condemned
protesters for reportedly yelling death
to police outside the hospital where two
los angeles county sheriff police
department deputies
are being treated and in critical
condition after being shot have you seen
the video by the way
yeah kai have you seen the video if you
got the video to for for people if
they've not seen it
this is the visual okay just so you know
so they're in their
uh a car this this person that's walking
up
originally they had no plans of doing
anything
he's about to walk by then all of a
sudden he pulls out his gun and he
starts shooting
okay in the in the 20s the window's open
or no uh
i don't think this angle it looks like
it's open but it may not be open
the the cop that they that he that the
person shot at got a 26 year old kid
she's 24 years old she's hospitalized
not in good conditions
trump said if either one of them dies
if either one of these cops dies he says
this person is going to be
getting the death penalty and and uh you
know for
for that to be taking place then the
local sheriff in la came out and said
hey lebron since you really lives really
matter to you why don't you match 175
a donation that we got to lebron this
was just said last night so
what are your thoughts you're you're in
l.a right now what are your thoughts
about this uh so disturbing on on
multiple levels this
is sick it's it's unbelievable it's very
unsettling but
i think almost as bad as the fact that
these protesters get into the hospital
here's a quote
according to the sheriff's department
the protesters were blocking the
entrance and exit of the hospital
emergency
room and one of them was yelling we hope
they die
i mean here's the scary thing for me
this is so organized right for
protesters
to be on the spot to a know where the
hospital is to get down there
to be in front of the hospital to have
these types of chance er
there's a big thing brewing here that's
uh that's quite scary lebron's probably
not gonna do anything i doubt if he's
gonna match that
he probably would have done it right
away did you hear that the black lives
matters uh
blocked his blocked lakers bus yesterday
and and there was
something going on in florida as well so
lebron seems to be in the crosshairs on
both sides
trying to get his attention but look i
hope that i mean there's not much else
to say trump even took heat for saying
that how can that be a controversial
statement to say
that these guys need to be brought to
justice immediately and have a death
penalty you know
uh attached to the to the sentence but
you know you know what's my biggest
challenge but lebron by the way
i've been in u.s since november 20th
1990.
what's special about november 20 1990 is
that's the year where the finals were
lakers against the bulls so i watch
michael make that shot over sam perkins
where he goes up and he switches for no
reason and comes up left-handed saying
sam perkins was trying to block my shot
as if sam perkins with a six-inch
vertical leap can block
michael's shot right who was high most
of the time by the way i i
never see sam perkins play that guy he's
got a good left-handed shot by the way
the three-pointer used to hit him
but but i've been a laker fan for 29 30
years now
it's the first year i'm now rooting for
the lakers you know why here's why
to me michael if there was a political
issue
he would say i'm giving a million
dollars to black university or black
college and i'm giving a million dollars
to charity of a police department or
sheriff and he would talk about how the
cops protected him so well throughout
his career right
there's nothing that's unifying about
lebron
james the only thing unifying lebron
james is anybody that agrees with him
that's it
you have to be a blm supporter for him
to unify
if you're not you won't hear anything
from him big difference when a guy
that's the face of the league
is treating the the politics that was
just purely one-sided yeah
and if he says it's not my
responsibility it's not on me you're the
face of the league
you call yourself the king the king
dictates what direction the nba goes 100
and everything good and bad that's going
on with today's nba is because of the
king because you are the king
so i you know i i would love for him to
come out i'd love to be wrong
i'd love to be wrong yeah but i highly
thought he's going to come out and
support the situation you know michael
had the great quote he goes republicans
buy shoes too so he you know
had business interests at the forefront
of most everything he did as well
michael was very savvy very smart
that's why he stayed neutral but so does
lebron lebron's media company is
doing very very well i mean he's spring
kill yeah
yes they've come to hollywood and
they've they've been very very
successful so
you would think somebody like that would
maybe want to straddle the line a little
bit more because
personally i look at lebron as a social
activist that also plays basketball
i think it's the other way no i don't i
look at his basketball as being
secondary i agree with you and it's so
sad because they're going to walk to the
finals probably
and they'll probably win it all i mean
the thing that's going to
i don't want to get all sports on you
but i mean their free throw shooting's
horrendous right so that could cost them
down the road but
he has a chance to to seize this mantle
of being the only guy to win three
championships
with three different teams and lead him
all the way and he's gonna blow it
because he's
offending more people than he's
generating uh excitement but
but the thing i will give him credit for
i don't think he really cares
doesn't seem like it yeah i don't think
he knows what he's doing yeah i mean
he's dropping fbombs on social media the
whole thing
not not that he he knows what he's doing
i don't think he knows what he's doing
i think he knows who he wants to be and
he could care less if he's losing half
the audience or not hey pat why
do you have a problem with that though i
don't have if you know who you are and
you know what you want to be and you
stand for something
what's wrong with that yeah for me i get
it i like people that are willing to
like for example
do you remember when the jesse smallett
thing that took place
do you remember when that took place of
course do you remember the first time
they asked trump about it what trump
said
no do you remember what trump said to
the tune that he didn't believe it or
something no no
no he believed that at first going to
follow that's right he said
we got to catch him this is not fair
that we got a you know
justice needs to be served he defended
jesse smallett yeah
and there's no way in the world he would
support jesse smallett
right after finding out the story his
immediate reaction
is to do what support he's not like that
so no matter how
how much people say that trump is
divisive trump is not as divisive as
lebron's device hey i'll say one more
thing i think this nba bubble is putting
these guys
in in a very weird environment you
listen to doc rivers comments i mean doc
stick to basketball right now no one
really is looking for you
to become a political activist and
that's all he seems to be doing as well
now but i think you're in a hotel room
maybe your wife's there but not your
kids some of your family
your your normal routine is out the
window you have 18 to 20 hours of down
time a day
all you have is your phone and social
media i think that's adding a little
fuel to it and it's gonna
you know go another month too if they
make the finals are you telling these
nba players they should shut up and
dribble i'm not saying that at all i
think that's what's going on i'm saying
the bubble is affecting them and i think
they're having more time
to not be around normal society where
you might have a little bit more open
mind about things so here's well
everyone's dealing with some sort of
you know covet bubble right now they're
literally dealing with the bubble but i
think everything is so amplified right
now
and i mean my biggest problem like just
for me
okay so if you don't if you don't find
what happened to the police officers
[ __ ] disgusting then you're on the
wrong side of the equation here ladies
and gentlemen like that is disgusting
so the people that for whatever reason
support that
you're hurting your cause here gentlemen
or ladies and gentlemen let's see if
lebron's tweeted about it i haven't even
checked i mean if i'm
if he has tweeted about it and saying
something especially it's his town
it's his city nope not one tweet
not one tweet about it he should not one
tweet about it so
the biggest problem i'm just gonna say
one thing the problem these days
is everything is so polarized it's this
or that
your blm or your your black lives matter
or your blue lives matter you're red or
you're blue
you're you're your maga or your blm it's
why can't we all
just be a little bit of just another a
few comments here to respond for both of
you guys what you said one
i don't mind uh athletes being uh
sharing their opinions if it's sincere
like for example cap
he knelt and he says here's what this is
well there was a lot of you know
hypocrisy behind his movement that what
he did mom's you know
white he's half white and you know then
he wears the pig
socks while he's playing in miami i mean
look now you're playing with fire you're
talking about
people that escaped castro so you know
but ali
when ali did it ali also got along with
everybody on both sides ali was still
likeable when him and you know they were
going at it with a couple different
people
i i don't have i don't he was actually
you would be his biggest
enemy when they would do interviews he
would he would always stand up
but at the same time he was partying
with everybody
you know ali was good with everybody ali
wasn't just one-sided guy when you read
the stories about it if you go to his
museum in kentucky louisville if you've
never been
highly recommended we're doing an event
there actually sapalas and vargas and
delways and kahindi and
my mission mason they're doing an event
there in january which i'm looking
forward to going to because i love the
ali museum this is what i will say about
this part here
this whole message is not about lebron
it's not about doc reverse it's about
these two sheriffs
my concern is the following here's my
biggest concern um
yesterday we're having a meeting here
okay and
one of my sales reps asked me a question
and says
what do you say when the person says
this
okay and i said what do you mean so what
do you say if the person says this and
they say if you don't do this i won't do
this
i said the reason why this person is
saying this is because they
feel comfortable being able to say that
to you what do i mean by that
you know how you sit with somebody on
somebody says shut up you know
and you don't like it you know how
people say shut up you know it's it's
not like a
uh a bad thing to say don't you say shut
up
i had a girl i worked with we're good
till today
she's won the best right now what we do
with the business she had a tendency of
saying this very quickly to everybody
and so one day she said it to me i said
can i whisper something to you just you
and i she said yes i said have i ever
told you to shut up
she said never i said please don't say
to me either i don't like the
terminology shut up
just don't say it to me she says i'm so
sorry i said no you don't have to
apologize it's very normal i actually
don't think you have anything negative
to say about it
but moving forward i'm not going to say
shut up you don't need to say shut up
let's have that mutual respect for one
another
she said okay so the next time you know
we're saying something just like oh
shout out i'm so sorry i said no just
the fact that you catch yourself guess
what
i respect the fact that you're
respecting me let me tell you what's
going on here what the bigger concern
is people are thinking it's okay to
shoot cops right now
and that's a byproduct of politics
people in california think it's okay to
shoot cops right now
so as much as garcetti is coming out and
saying this stuff
you are indirectly making people think
that they are doing something good to go
after cops
because it's a way of getting their 15
seconds of fame and they're going to be
talked about and oh my gosh blm is going
to say oh phenomenal let's go defund the
police all this other stuff
you have to be very careful what you
recognize for if you tell your kid
kid great job there's this book that was
on parenting he said
the the author of this book says
whatever you recognize your kids for and
give attention
for they're going to keep doing it
meaning if the kid is sick you only hug
your kids and tell them you love them
when they're kid and they're sick
they're going to keep telling you
they're sick you got to hug and kiss
your kids
when they're doing okay you got to do
good to them when nothing's going on
but if you recognize them and you laugh
at them saying a stupid joke to somebody
and you think it's funny using
bad words they're going to keep doing it
because it's a form of recognition
california is indirectly promoting
these types of behavior and it starts
with newsom and it starts with garcetti
and all that stuff needs to be stopped
by the way
shout out to newsom because newsome did
send a tweet out
and one of the things i like about what
newsome did the last 24 hours you guys
know how i am about newsome if he does
stuff
i'll call him up but i got to give him
respect as well and i know some of the
people that are watching the same path
i cannot believe you're going to say
this about newsome let me tell you what
at least he did
and whether you say it's good or not
here's what he did do yesterday
he got up there and he says a 31 year
old mother and a 24 year old are
fighting for their lives because of this
cowardly
horrific act the perpetrator must be
quickly brought to justice praying for a
full recovery for the deputies
and then she has the name and his wife
and him are praying
and are keeping their loved ones and
their thoughts listen and he did that
immediately
respect good good freak no i'm giving
you something he's the governor he
should
whatever yes i know you're giving him
but what i'm saying is and on top of
that let me tell you what he did
yesterday
the fires are going on in california
yeah trump flies in to meet with him
he doesn't say pulling off a publicity
stunt i will never meet with him if he
comes in he says no
let's sit down newsome sat right here
while trump sat right here and trump was
being briefed on what's going on in
california
and trump was listening to everybody and
news i'm sitting here now think about
how uncomfortable he is his ex-wife is
dating his son
let me say this one more time governor
newsome's ex-wife
is dating his son and he still has the
audacity sit right
next to trump i respect i know what his
positions are
i know where he's at with this but i
respect the fact that he's willing to do
this
you cannot by the way i hope he's
realizing you can
out there and say you cannot show up to
church oh but you can go out there and
protest and you cannot do that
this hypocrisy needs to stop at the top
because these guys are thinking it's
okay
and i hope this is the last shooting
towards sheriffs and cops
but unfortunately if i'm a betting man
in vegas i'm telling you i don't think
selassie
well especially not next two months and
when you consider in chicago
did you see that story where 36th street
gangs have formed a coalition to say
that they would shoot cops on site
if they were armed and stuff so the
retic that rhetoric is so dangerous you
know
i will say that too i think um i think
newsome is open-minded when it comes to
things like that and i don't think he
hates trump
as much as maybe people think he does
because he's actually
praised trump in the past at least he
has the open mind to sit next to him
and have this discussion i don't think
trump hates california that's the
impression out there too he has a house
in beverly hills
or he loves california i think he loves
hollywood he loves aspects of it so he
wants to help now the funniest visual of
their two meeting was
gavin newsom had a mask on and trump
didn't right i mean that just
kind of summed up the differences right
there yeah let me ask you two
californians
uh a question if california was a stock
right with everything that's going on
right now the homeless issue with the
uh knew some u-haul employee of the year
the fires the craziness the shootings
are you buying california are you
selling california long term i'll go
first
easy buying it's a blue chip stock like
ibm or like you would preach about coke
or mcdonald's or something like that
it's going to have maybe a downturn
right now it's going to be rough but you
can't recreate
the the natural resources that state has
the weather the climate the palm trees
the coastline so i'm buying definitely
you're buying i'm buying i'm actually
surprised because you've been i love
california i've known you for a few
months
every time you've heard me i have
[ __ ] california it sucks it's burning
down well no no no buying though
i'm i am i am seeing what's going on
there and i'm very disturbed by it and
i'm hurt by it and it's very
disappointing downward trend but
you're not buying buying you're buying
calories i'm buying what say you pbd
uh i don't think i'm buying for the next
few years
okay i'm shorting right now and then i'm
buying
in the next few years that's what i'm
doing like airline stock almost yeah
and you know for me it's it's it's a
couple of things that you have to
realize
number one is you know the reason why
i'm banking on america
still buying for america is because the
person running america
still is someone that's advancing what
america was founded on california
unfortunately is going a different
direction
you know i have morale and tikran that
are in california right now yeah i said
how are things in california i said uh
she says uh fires in pasadena are
terrible are kitty all this other stuff
they said how about homelessness their
reaction was like this oh pat
they're everywhere so what do you mean
real quick everybody if you're
in california or if you're yeah you know
around the country would you buy
california stock right now
are you selling california stock well
pat tells the story chime in so they're
saying it's everywhere homelessness is
everywhere in california right now we'll
see what's going to happen again
long-term blue chip yeah
silicon valley but don't forget man
people move you got to realize people
move if you
don't make the climate good for a
certain community they move
look what's happening with hollywood you
know did you ever
think people were going to do auditions
in austin and atlanta
did you think a tyler perry who's now
officially a
black billionaire wow that's what he's
one of the uh you know
he came out there was some statistic
that came out about but by the way i'm a
die-hard tyler perry fan
i think tyler perry is a solid guy what
he's doing but i don't think california
is going to have that big of an argument
if they keep going the way they're going
right i hope i'm wrong
you know i hope i'm wrong and i hope tom
you are right but we'll see what's going
to happen
we got 50 50 results sell sell buy buy
sell
california needs a correction let's talk
about the finals how about we talk about
the
stuff okay uh uh so here's what happened
bobby jordan
36 people have died in california
because of fire okay
36 people uh the number right now
in the state of california is 4.6
million acres in california is on fire
right now
ky if you can bring up the video 4.6
million acres that's a lot of acres by
the way you buy a house it's an acre
you're sitting on a nice lot 4.6 million
acres
and specifically if you go to san
francisco's orange sky
okay just type in uh on youtube san
francisco orange sky go to youtube
sky fire uh
go to videos yeah that's what it looks
like but go to videos because the videos
kind of gives you go to the one that's
two minutes and 29 seconds go back
go back one go to the sky news one yeah
right there that one right there watch
the skyline of san francisco looking
more like an image from mars
the orange glow from wildfires
the middle of the day felt like dusk and
it is
unnerving i was wondering what time it
was
and then i looked outside and it looked
like doomsday
i mean you could tell something is
horribly going wrong
and as far as going to work and
breathing in all this
this pollution is definitely not
intelligent guys
it feels like the end of the world it's
pretty scary look at this look what she
says
she's a die hard california lifelong
californian and
it makes me weak can i sell done to my
poor
and those fires continue to rage across
the western united states
driven on by strong dry winds burning
more of california this year
than ever before watch this it's about
to get uh the next
part unprecedented number of fires
destroying some
whole communities it is the speed with
which these fires spread
that's especially alarming
the people who lived in this
neighborhood had barely any time to
escape
sheriff's coming through going level
three get out
get out and uh yeah grab some papers
grab some papers and stuff
didn't make it out deaths have been
confirmed in a number of states
and officials say that number will go up
watch we expect to see a great deal of
loss
uh as a result of these fires both in
terms of
structures and in terms of human lives
um
it as i mentioned earlier could be the
greatest loss
in human lives and property due to
wildfire
video thank you so you know these fires
that's going on with california for
somebody that is from california tom
what do you got to say about it
devastating it's so heartbreaking it's
unbelievable those are human lives those
fires move
so fast there's nothing you can do what
are you going to do get a couple tankers
in the air you can't stop them
uh you know i live in southern
california in manhattan beach
you look at the weather forecast no
clouds sunny it's dark
i mean it's not as bad as san francisco
but but it's it's everywhere i've got a
lot of experience with wildfires though
the woolsey fire in malibu a few years
ago my daughter went to pepper goes to
just graduated from pepperdine she had a
run for her life to get out of that
thing came over the canyon
uh unbelievable and i live in manhattan
beach which is about 27 miles away from
malibu i could see
flames when you look towards malibu
that's how intense these fires are but
this is unbelievable
the thing that's really upsetting is a
lot of people want to make this only a
climate issue
right but a lot of these fires are
man-made they're arsonists that are
starting these fires one guy was
arrested for starting seven of them
in oregon and these things people
arsonists are going out there
yes or like these maniacs are going out
there and starting these fires
so when you see you know that woman that
was talking and crying i mean
your life is they come through those
small towns so fast
and then they'll they'll they'll uh
encompass the city where there's no
exits
there was one town where they had to
airlift everybody out there last week so
it's unbelievable we just see the
headlines and we see the smoke and we
see the skyline with the with the orange
hue but man it's it's really really bad
i think the question is is it climate
change or is it
fires like is it does this have to do
with the climate or does this have to do
with california's not being responsible
and figuring out a way to solve this
why can't it be both why can't it be
both so
so if you think it is climate change
that's not what i said i think it's both
i think climate change things are
getting hotter you know
i think that is a factor but arsonists
there's my my question i don't have a
major point because i don't i don't know
being in florida the worst thing that
happens is a freaking hurricane maybe in
september
california is insane with these fires
it's crazy my question is this
the entrepreneur spirit in california is
crazy silicon valley crazy billionaires
tech companies things are happening the
cloud the software why
can't they figure this out why can't
something be done here
right forget about another social media
app forget about another freaking cloud
computing app figure out these [ __ ]
fires or you won't have a state anymore
california you know the climate does
have something to do with it when it
doesn't rain
everything's a tinder box so anyway
you're on the ocean
you're on the coast yeah but what's
happening central america
once you get it plus the land is so
expansive and then you get the trees
which is the kindling too
it's it's maybe worse in oregon so it's
the whole west coast
i don't know if you can put everything
too short correct it's not just
california oregon
washington state i want to say why don't
you why don't you put a
bonus together why don't you put a
incentive together for the first person
that does this we're going to be giving
xyz on the state of california
yes why don't you put an incentive
program so the one thing i do like i
like the fact that trump flew out and
had the meeting with governor newsom and
everybody in california one it shows
leadership from trump's standpoint too
it shows that newsom i mean what choice
does he have to say no to meet with him
but he
was willing to meet with him but now i'd
like to see that meeting take place
with musk i'd like to see that meeting
take place with the guys from google
i'd like to see that take place with
peter thiel i'd like to see that take
place with cal tech i'd love to see that
with jack dorsey
i'd love to see a twitter campaign
coming out i'd like to see
a massive incentive being creative
microsoft and social battle everything
on the left
somebody come up with an incentive what
kind of an incentive could you do
everything is incentive driven how can
you not give the incentive to solve this
who's going to fix this pat
is the government going to fix this or
entrepreneurs no it's going to be but
the entrepreneur
must have an incentive there needs to be
a massive incentive financial incentive
that's what entrepreneurs are driven by
it's either recognition or incentive
either make them be in the history books
for doing something
like how do how do charities raise money
your name is going to be on this wall
you know your name's going to be on
legacy
yeah give them a legacy or give them
money give them one of those two things
that's what entrepreneurship
give them a percentage of what the state
doesn't spend on trying to put these
fires
oh yeah yeah it's here's the scary thing
every year gets worse
you know 2016 2017 this is happening and
then we had all those rains in 2016 and
2017 where you think this is done
yeah right we're not having to deal with
this anymore and just it gets worse
every year you think these lands burn
and they can't burn again but that's how
big california
is there's always more land to char but
by the way where is pelosi based out of
san francisco what has she said about
the phone oh she's been on the front
line she's like holding a hose
haven't you seen her she's driving a
helicopter airdrop she's all over this
yeah she's all over this
her hair looks great though her hair
does look great so very impressive
so there's homelessness homelessness
problem going on in california
and now we got fired now we got cops
being shot
uh president trump has to go on an
emergency meeting california i mean just
what a wonderful job that state is doing
just
a great job but they're going to win a
championship they're going to win
no parade though we can't even l.a will
win a championship this year we've got
the dodgers too by the way
la will win you as a miami heat fan
you're saying zero chance
i'm saying i'm saying no i i'm saying
all the miami friends that he has i want
you to unfollow him if you're a true
miami heat fan and you love adam
i cannot believe he just took a shot at
the heat i'm saying all your buddies
your party with our friend right you're
gonna get texts right now just so you
know that
all his buddies are stupid to text you
right now
okay but you did i said la will win a
championship this year that's right
could be the clippers meaning it could
be the clippers if they can get by the
nuggets but
let's not get too sportsy we're gonna
lose half our audience right here okay
by the way we're at 1.9 000 viewers we'd
love to hit 2 000. i think we've only
hit that once oh yeah press thumbs up
if you're watching this and join us
press thumbs up so it gets picked up and
share the podcast as you're watching
this some guy goes i'm following adam
right now
no please don't okay so let's talk about
something weird here and something
uncomfortable here but something that
needs to be addressed because it's been
all over tv
cuties with netflix okay cuties with
netflix
new movie that came out um
if you've seen this movie kai if you
want to put up the poster with netflix
the the two that we have
the original poster is that one on the
right this one
and netflix oh this is the original
that's the original one what does
netflix make it this
oh so the original is this shows that
shots makes this yeah
so netflix goes with the provocative one
but this is the one that the original
one
uh movie that came out did well in the
sundance it did very well and then it
comes to netflix and here's what happens
the trailer has nearly 12 million views
okay by the way if you can change the
picture i don't want it to stay for too
long the trailer has 12 million views
it has 47 000 likes
2 million dislikes let me say this one
more time
the trailer has 12 million views go to
the trailer on youtube just to see the
stats as the most
latest updated stats cuties
so the trailer has uh uh uh you were
right yeah cuties uh
uh oh there it go okay so what number is
it okay 12.1 million views
it's got 48 000 likes 1.9 million
dislikes by the way
even that song that that girl sang
remember a few years ago that girl had
that one song
hey friday and they said it's the worst
song in the history of songs
and poor girl got so many dislikes it
was the most hated video of the year on
youtube do you remember that song of
course
sam works out too no no no no let's stay
on this topic we'll come back to friday
i know adam really wants to listen to it
okay i never heard it
yeah it's uh where's it at 1.2 million
to 3.8 million is it bad
most hated video of the year the ratio
is a lot better
she was likeable though i liked her only
this girl can make people hate
friday friday the most like go back to
the video go back to the video
12 million like 12 million views 47 000
likes 48 000 likes 1.9 million dislikes
and 598 hundred signatures calling for
people to cancel their netflix
subscription
in light of cuties being added to its
library of kind by the way good friend
of jose gaiton okay he's one of our
co-founders
he sits on he's one of the field
advisory board members he cancels
netflix wow netflix lost
nine billion dollars in france where the
film was released in theater on august
19 cuties did not steer much controversy
the movie won a directing award for
sundance institute in february
they called to remove the film calls to
remove the film
have been amplified by supporters of a
conspiracy theory that top democrats and
celebrities are behind a global child
trafficking ring
it's currently trending number seven on
netflix
and then uh my film is a mirror of
today's society a mirror sometimes
difficult to look onto and accept but
still so true
we can't blame our children for what we
value in our society
thoughts on the movie tom zenner as a
parent yep okay has a parent with an 11
year old
boy but not girl those these kids are
11. uh i have a 14 year old daughter i
think any movie that sexually
uh exploits children in any way is bad
is evil
i will say this i wasn't offended by
this as much as i thought i would be we
talked about it a lot you hear a lot of
bugs watch the movie i didn't watch the
movie yet but
i i did the trailer i watched a little
bit of the movie
i watched the interview with the
director i thought i would be appalled
i'm upset but i'm not appalled
um i think 11 the thing that really
bothers me is
i don't see that i mean i live in la i
don't see 11 year old girls my son is 11
years old i'm around these kids i don't
see them
at that age doing that i think the
director had a unique
upbringing in senegal or wherever she
was born and raised
very very you know muslim background her
mother did not look like she was
you know supporting her in any way so
this is highly personal telling her
story
um i think a lot of those uh a lot this
is organized i think against netflix
right now now i'm a prude you know and
i'm christian
i would be the one person that would be
really sickened by this and i'm not
happy about it
i'm not as offended offended as i was i
thought i would be but
i just think the age of 11 to even like
paint that picture that these kids are
sexual at that age
is disgusting well let me ask you this
question you just brought up a good
point kai
can you pull up to see it what what is
it is it a pg-13 movie is it a movie
that tico could watch
you know because we have filters on
netflix where my kids can go watch
movies that they want
is it allowed on them to watch it or is
it at least
a what do they have it as cute rotten
tomatoes 90
what does that mean i wouldn't be
surprised that rotten tomatoes gives it
5 like this movie uh one point three
percent rating
uh just see what it's uh uh is it a tv
tv
or a mature audience it is a mature
audience
okay go up what does a mature audience
mean by the way like what
age i mean i mean type in tv tv
just type in tvma what it means i'm
assuming 16 plus tvma what does it mean
i think there's a space but there's okay
free dictionary
uh the tv uh uh program 17 intended to
be viewed
okay uh okay fine so they have it for
mature
under 70. so it's a movie for adults
they want parents to see it not
necessarily kids to see it
uh uh that's that's actually very good
to know that that's uh that's out there
okay
adam what are your thoughts about it
yeah obviously i don't have kids but all
my friends do
um i have a different opinion um
obviously um
it's disgusting i mean this sexualizing
11 year olds is not
anything that anyone would support is
not mainstream um
but i did a little research on this this
is the
this is it served its purpose
what do i mean by that this is a shock
jock like alex jones saying
i believe something crazy and i'm just
going to run with it and i'm going to
serve
she did this for a reason i'm just going
to read a few things this movie is
supposed to make people feel
uncomfortable it shines the light on
this
issue she says you have to watch the
movie to judge you so what
my film is a mirror of today's society a
mere sometimes
difficult to look into and accept but
still true we can't blame our children
for what we value in our society
so what's my point she made this to make
people feel uncomfortable she made this
for to us to
speak about she made this to stir
controversy because if it didn't
now there's the problem if people did
not speak up about this if people were
not appalled by this
and people were like yeah it was a good
movie and didn't say [ __ ]
then we'd have a problem the fact that
so many people have a problem with it
is a good sign i mean that's a good way
of spinning it
okay to to say that i get what this
isn't me i'm not saying you i'm saying
that's a good way of spinning it to to
say i made it so people would get pissed
off about it fine okay i understand like
ann coulter writes certain books with
certain copies and
bill maher asks ann coulter do you just
write stuff to piss people off
yeah is that your business model she was
asked the same question on the view she
was one of the first people that said
bill maher asked her who's the person
that can win the presidency she says
today
donald trump everybody started laughing
she was the first
major pundit type of name that went out
there and said that
so i think it's a good spin on what she
said if that's her business model fine
that is a business model you can do
today
my concern is a little bit different of
a concern here's what my concern is
so remember earlier we talked about and
won the episodes adam you would remember
this where
in politics tom uh brought this up tom
ellsworth brought it up to me
he said 44 of democrats are going to
vote democrat you can't do nothing about
it they just go down the ballot done
right
42 percent of republicans are gonna vote
down the ballot you can't do nothing
about it
four percent of libertarians and
dependents green they're gonna go down
the ballot they can't do nothing about
it that's ninety percent
we got ten percent you got ten percent
left that is the one that's going to
determine
and if it's 60 40 it's going to be a tie
it's what he was saying right okay
so there's a group of people that watch
this video and watch this movie and they
say
they're freaking disgusting this is
terrible there's some people that are
gonna watch the movie and they're gonna
say wow very educational i liked it good
perspective i took a lot of like people
in france yeah apparently
there's going to be a group of people
that watch and they're going to say
that are not going to watch it i don't
say there's no way in the world i would
spend my time watching a movie like this
right like me
right i would i don't watch that movie
by the way kai watch it last night for
be ed
really yeah kai watch it on 1.5 to get
a perspective on it but here's the
problem
there's 10 percent of people that are
going to watch it that could potentially
influence them to be thinking about
something and let me explain to what i
mean by 10 of people that can be
influenced something
so you watch the show cops if you watch
your show cops
how do you watch you show cops you watch
it and shout out to figure out what you
can do to skirt the camera no
not you when you watch your show cops
what do you say you're watching i watch
it for entertainment
yeah but if i'm a criminal you know how
i watch your show cops i'm like okay
got it like in the nfl yeah like guys
who went to prison friends of mine
who've gone to prison i have a lot of
friends that have gone to prison have
come come out
obviously i've interviewed a lot of
people that have spent a lot of time in
prison you know what they tell you
prison was a training camp to learn how
to commit other types of crimes
you go to jail you only sold wheat or
you sold a couple of things but i went
in i learned how to do
this master's degree this spring
training and this
as much as she may have good intentions
there's certain v like okay
think about it this way is there a
visual in your life as a kid growing up
that you wish you never had
yeah you don't need to say it but is
there a visual you had as a kid that you
wish you never had
do you have one yeah i'm not asking what
it is do you have one though yes
it could be a father slapping your mom
in the face you wish you never had that
okay it could be a sibling
getting smashed on the floor and
somebody hit them with the knee it could
be something sexual it could be
something you saw
that you wish you never saw we're never
going to talk about it as adults
we keep it in our minds that visual
messed with you the rest of your life
and you're 41 years old you wish you
never had that
i'm not 41. you're 40 years old you're
39 about to be 40 right 39 about to be
40.
sure there are certain visuals we're
better off
not having this is one of them the world
is a better place whether you watch us
or not we don't need to have certain
visuals be in people's minds that's the
only thing i'm saying about
making movies like well then who is the
villain is it netflix or is it the
director and i'll tell you that i i
think if i had to choose
that's art that's what artists do so i'm
not going to blame the director
okay someone had to pay you're blaming
the distributor well i mean
if there's blame to go out and i think
the rage right now is kind of focused on
netflix
and i think if you look at the poster i
mean they sex those kids
up to a ridiculous degree that again i
have kids that age i don't see that if
that was a 14 year old it would make
more sense
but not at the age of 11. we just
cracked 2 000
we appreciate you guys your comments
we're seeing them
give a thumbs up you know it's hurt
netflix hasn't it i mean
nine billion dollars you know they lost
nine billion dollars but uh
does that bother them i don't think so
because they're worth how many hundred
i don't i don't think that there's
anything to netflix so if you ask me
hastings is sitting up there and just
going to say well this thing's going to
pass us by we're going to be all right
here's my next follow-up question for
you guys i asked you if you were going
to buy
california stock what are you doing with
netflix stock you're buying you're not
going to sell it netflix is not going
away you know what if i had
between hulu and netflix i pick hulu i
like hulu better you're like
i could live without netflix easily i
think i could easily could you live
without hulu
no because it has live tv that's how we
get live tv
interesting and i think uh they do
better commercials if you ask me
that's the best damian lillard and all
these commercials they do it's
phenomenal
and with that fake agent these classes
yeah i love the the marketing that they
have over there so we'll see we'll see
what's going to happen there let's see
what we want to hit up next
you know what let's hit up uh uh uh
navid afghani okay why don't we hit this
up because i think um
i don't know if you guys are following
the story or not but i want to hit this
up and kai i don't know if you have the
video or not if you don't it's all good
it's totally fine
if you can just pull up the picture so
we can talk about what happened here so
uh and if you can go to my uh twitter
profile
as well just to show what happens so for
those of you that don't know
for those of you that don't know naveed
afghani
is a wrestler in iran a national
champion if you can pull up his picture
so we know what he looks like
he's a national champion and iran
wrestler two years ago he decides to
protest
against what was going on in iran with
other people and his two brothers okay
so he goes out there and he protests
and you know the economy in iran's not
doing very well
it's challenging times of course there's
the sanctions that u.s has put so these
guys are having a hard time and he goes
up against the prime minister says we
need to do
something in iran because this is not
going the right direction
long story short he ends up getting
arrested because he is a national
champion he's a figurehead people know
who he is
he gets arrested they take him in they
go
and they put oil in his uh not oil
alcohol in his nose for him to admit
that he killed somebody
so eventually to stop from being
tortured he says what
fine i did it okay they announced
just two weeks ago they're going to
execute this guy iran announced that
they're going to execute him and kill
him right
there's three brothers they decide to
execute him but the world's like
maybe they're not going to do it he's
going to get 74 whiplashes and then get
executed
his other brother is going to get 74
whiplashes and go to jail for
52 years or 54 years his other brother
is going to get 74 lashes on his back
and go to jail for
27 years okay this is what the charges
were against these three brothers
for simply protesting right i go out
there on twitter if you can post my
twitter a
tweet that i put up and here's what i
said on twitter i made a video about it
go up go up go up go up go up
a little bit higher you're almost there
you're almost there right there
so i go up and i said posit deposit and
i said
those who live in a country with human
rights rarely think about it
and those who don't can't stop thinking
about it iran hasn't valued human rights
for over 40 years
if you agree with this please retweet
and tag olympics let's save the life of
navidad
my message here was directed to the
olympics the reason why i was directed
to the olympics was because
olympics can do something about this to
say if you do
and move forward with this execution
guess what we are going to
cancel iran competing in the olympics so
i announced this then if you go
up there to a cnn article to see what
the olympics said just type in naf
nafeet afghari navid afghani in the
search
go to search and type in navidad right
there cnn it just came up cnn first one
go on the second article go on the
second article and let's read this
together
iranian champion wrestling navidafari
executed despite the international
campaign so he was executed
a couple days ago if you can make it a
little bit smaller kai so i can read it
to the audience right there
so the international olympic committee
said it was shocked by the announcement
in letters thomas bach the ioc president
had made direct personal appeals to the
supreme leader
and to the president of iran this week
and asked for mercy
for navid afghari while respecting the
sovereignty
of the islamic republic of iran the
statement said it is deeply
upsetting that the pleas of athletes
from around the world and all the behind
the scenes work of the ioc together with
the noc of iran
united world wrestling and national iran
wrestling federation
did not achieve our goal fine so you
went and you played so i said tag
olympics
we tagged the olympics on instagram
facebook and twitter maybe 10 000 times
i said okay so they make this statement
they reached out to iran iran doesn't
listen to what the olympics say
say screw you we're going to execute him
even though you like this or not
mother comes out if you watch your
mother's speech you will be heartbroken
if you listen to what the mother says
now
here's a couple stats for people that
are watching this
iran is the number two country in the
world for executions
last year was 253 people were executed
this is not the death penalty by the way
this is execution there's a big
difference between execution
and death penalty execution is
what he called a german type of
execution you know
and death penalty is a different kind of
death penalty you go up there you do
obviously there's a form of execution
but you go through execution
out of the 253 people that were executed
13 of them were
live in person let me say this one more
time
in iran 253 people were executed
13 of them were live people came and saw
a person being executed
in the streets in the street it's it's a
statement if you do this this is what's
going to happen to you
they're the number two country in the
world in execution number one you know
china
you know who's a no more country in the
world china's number one
china's number one iran's number two so
then i said okay
let me pull up the list of what
countries have been banned from the
olympics kai can you pull up the history
of countries that have been banned
from the olympics this is the step we
have olympic countries banned from the
olympics the banning of the russian
athletes
team reolympics not the first time a
teamwork country has been banned from
participating in the olympics here's a
timeline of countries that have been
banned
1920 antwerp five countries were banned
due to the environment the first world
war austria bulgaria turkey hungary and
germany find paris
in 1924 the band of germany following
world war ii makes sense through
though austria bulgaria turkey hungary
were allowed to compete
1948 london german and japan were barred
for their participation in the second
world war
fine so germany and japan were barred
1964 tokyo
south africa was banned by the ioc for
taking part due to its
oppressive uh uh uh how do you pronounce
that word apatite
regime which say that apartheid
apartheid which is apartheid is what
like
you know it's segregation blacks and
whites the whole
segregation exactly so they were famous
in south africa and by the way
year after year after year after year so
68 72 this goes on with
south africa you can keep going lower
and lower so south africa has been
by the way 1968 north korea competed
against second uh
nfo in 1966 which meant they were
suspended by the ioc causing the nation
to miss 1968 olympics
as well so in 1968 mexico north korea
couldn't compete
1978 uh 1972 munich south africa
as well as zimbabwe was banned from
participant as other african countries
threatened pull out
if rodesa took part okay 1976 montreal
south africa south africa south africa
2000 sydney afghanistan was banned from
the olympics due to his discrimination
against women under taliban rule as well
as its prohibition
of sports of any kind and then you have
obviously 2016. many russian competitors
were banned following revelations of
state sponsored doping all athletes were
not okay
okay see all this stuff right okay so
let's come to today
okay olympics you pleaded for an athlete
to not be executed and iran didn't
listen
now what are you going to do are you not
going to say fine
you are banned from the next olympics so
now when you say that
some people say well that's not fair
because you are
making people's dreams not become a
reality in iran that are trained so hard
to go become
a olympic winner here's one thing you
have to realize i have an age i have an
agent that works for us his name is
morteza alborzi okay
phenomenal guy i met this guy when i was
23 years old he's a sweetheart of a guy
he's doing very well for himself and
in our company right now morteza albersi
out of la is a eight or a nine degree
black belt can you type in morteza
alborzi black belt morteza
alborzi black belt morteza spell it for
us two kai
z-a you got it actually perfect so far
he spells better farsi than
english by the way so al borji a-l-b-o-r
right there came up right
amortez alborzi black belt yeah okay
perfect
press that and then go to images okay
this guy's been all over the place when
it comes onto martial arts okay right
here
right there no you had it right just go
on that magazine that says masters go on
the magazine that says masters if you go
back that's him
alborzi okay eight degree nine degree
black belt
he was in jail in iran he's been one of
the top
olympic trainers and the judge not
judges but somebody that trained the
iranian team for the longest time right
he escaped he came to america he trained
here he trained a lot of students here
tens of thousands of students in beverly
hills have taken his classes
this kid this man has built so many
young boys that became leaders
moral of the story is this if the
olympics
are so serious about this movement why
don't you ban iran
and china of 20 the next olympics that
we have why don't we okay well i'll ask
you this question because you're flying
there
wouldn't wouldn't the regime in iran
right now look at a ban from the ioc
similar to a public execution like they
don't give a damn about promoting sports
in iran
they just want to suppress their people
stay in power so
that would almost strengthen them a
little bit to say
we're still going to do what we do and
execute people if we
perceive that you commit these crimes
they might embrace that because they
don't really care oh i don't think
that's how this works though
let me tell you how this works uh tom
how much longer are you going to
tolerate california mistreating you
at what level no but at what levels is a
breaking point for you
by the way i'm not this has got nothing
to do with our relationship whatever's
asking you right whatever the answer is
it's out there all right it exists okay
but but could california push you to a
breaking point of you saying you're
leaving
um yes okay i guess anything's possible
did that happen to me
could they push me out he left colombia
his family left mexico right i mean how
come how come we have 40 million
immigrants in the u.s
how come people are leaving other
countries i think iran thinks
their people won't do anything about it
and they have to understand this whole
sanction that trump put on iran why did
he put the sanctions on iran
strengthen saudi arabia okay why else
did he put the sanctions of iran
because it's evil maybe as a method of
saying hey and then he supported the
revolution of the people wanting to
protest against iran
right to for what for maybe a fall
of an empire in iran that is not
believing in human rights not taking
care of its people they're claiming what
they're doing the people are afraid
they're oppressed
i mean you're trying to get people to
have some kind of a freedom this would
be a certain statement that's being made
to say look we don't support
you know execution we don't support what
you're doing because you're doing that
look forget about the olympics
but i agree with you i think that's what
they should do but would it have any
effect
on the leadership in iran i i don't
think so couldn't there be a coup
isn't there this a country where that
could actually happen i couldn't see it
happening really in north korea
and some of these other places but don't
they have the ability there
to cover i mean with the support of the
us with the support of saudi arabia
to flip this eventually or is it too
difficult to flip what
the leadership in iran to get rid of
these of course you could do it i mean
of course you could do it it's not uh
how is that done
how is it done it's painful and it's
going to cost a lot of people's lives
and it's going to be a lot of young
lives this is why
it's not the younger generation that
doesn't want a revolution it's the older
generation that's telling their kids be
careful
don't go out there which i fully support
every parent would tell their kids that
but the opposition you know when you
look at when you talk to a lot of when
you meet a lot of persians you'll hear a
lot of people say things like this in
l.a
they'll say you know i don't i don't
know why it is man when i meet persians
man persons are
such good business people they're always
making money it's not that they're
making such good money
it's the fact that the business people
of iran left iran to come over here
it's not that they are the business
people of iran left iran it's not that
all persian people are business people
do you understand to make money it's
that they left iran to come over here
the business people that left iran
it's a filtering process that you have
the capitalists left yeah look i got
kids man i'd love to want to take my
kids to iran and quite frankly two years
ago i was gonna go on a
trip to iran with a few friends and you
know not publicize it just to go
to iran because i miss my country i was
born and i wanted to go to the streets i
was raised all this other stuff
but uh for me to go to iran today would
not be the smartest move to make to go
to iran today
there's a chance you would they'd be
waiting for you they would be waiting
for somebody i would love to set an
example with a guy like you
they would love nothing more than that
but i would love one day
to go there with a group of friends and
say hey here's what it looks like
it's a beautiful country man the history
of it is so beautiful to go to it but
i i you know heartbroken when i saw that
navidafkari was executed it's
unbelievable
how about his brothers iranians would
love to see a coup
a big part 50 uh no it's a bigger that
it's a big bigger than 50
questions but but here's the thing at
the only reason why that number could
change
is what quest one question at what cost
a hundred percent 95 would love to see a
coup
but at what cost then the cost is
only twenty percent or ten percent or
five percent would like to see you cool
with the cost i don't this makes sense
or not it's like you know someone i'm
saying like
what percentage of the world would like
to be a millionaire
well everybody of course but what
percentage is willing to work 80 hours a
week for 10 years
well not a big problem so it's at what
cost
am i willing to do we have any case
examples of coups
um initiated by the people obviously we
can't look at iraq
us came in there invaded them right or
we can't look at libya you know
type of thing what coups have been
successful over the last 50 well i mean
a revolution flipped iran
47 years ago 40 years ago so since then
the perfect example they have the
playbook for it in iran
kai you were you trying to say something
yeah we can't hear you here's the mic
a lot of the eastern european block had
revolutions when they broke when they
broke up from russia you're saying
yeah or the uss pat were you arab spring
there's another one yeah popping out
sure it's good
just recent ten years oh yeah look at
libya i mean look at these countries
gaddafi um were you surprised they
actually went through at the execution
to me personally i was a little bit
surprised
well um here's did you see what trump
tweeted yesterday about iran
type in the trump tweets and go to see
what he said about iran yesterday
middle of the night by the way i don't
know if you saw that or not did you guys
see that or no
have you seen what trump tweeted okay so
this is two days after the execution
go up a little bit to make sure it's not
that okay you're good it's not that one
keep going keep going keep going
this is what trump just said about iran
okay right there right there right there
right there click on that one right
there okay
click on it so we can read the whole
thing just yet according to press
reports iran may be planning an
assassination or other attack against
the united states in retaliation for the
killing of terrorist leader soleimani
which was carried out for his planning a
future attack murdering u.s troops and
the death and suffering
caused over so many years any attack by
iran in any form against the united
states will be met with an attack on
iran that will be
one thousand times greater in magnitude
right okay
that happens two days after the the
execution of navidad okay so you asked
the question
uh were you surprised because you were
surprised uh
i'm not surprised adam asked the
question yesterday which was a very good
question
uh you said something about do you know
don't you think iran
is trying to make a statement to say hey
man you keep bullying us and publicize
us
we're going to show you in a different
way trump tweeted please do
not execute this again okay thanks trump
so you're saying trump tweeted please do
not execute and they did i'm just saying
they're not gonna listen to trump
guys i'm seven years old looking outside
my window fourth grade in the fourth
floor in iran on gilbane hojet
and i'm seeing thousands of people
marching down the street flagellating
their backs you know what flagellating
is
self whipping themselves but it's
peeling the skin off your back so it's
leaving a trail of blood
and they're screaming mad bad ombre call
death upon america
the the the messaging of what the media
says to the iranian people about america
if you live in iran america is the
worst most evil empire in the world
if you live in iran it's their method of
preventing their citizens to leave to
come to iran come to us
because propaganda all propaganda north
korea north korea if you had a michael
jackson shirt on in the 80s you were the
coolest cat on campus
i'm telling you right in iran if you had
a michael jackson shirt on that was like
if you were a calvin klein or tommy
hilfiger shirt
you're the coolest guy on campus if
you've got a tommy you'll figure it sure
so yes i would i think majority of iran
would like to see it i just don't know
if it's gonna
i'll say this you know they didn't
listen to trump's plea he beg i mean hey
please do i mean he was very respectful
in that tweet where he asked them not to
execute the wrestler
i don't think they're gonna look at that
as bluster i think they believe
after four years he pretty much backs up
what he says
so right i mean a lot of times people
think of what trump's doing he's you
know a maniac with tweets or whatnot but
if they did something don't you believe
that a thousand times might be accurate
as far as what the retaliation would be
i mean don't you think the uh iranian
leadership might hate trump
um but don't think do you think they
respect him a little bit that that might
be true and they better
do you think he's kept him under his
thumb a little bit out of fear yeah so
my
my guesstimation is the following when
they retaliated after soleimani was
killed do you remember what iran did
do you remember what they attacked
a military base that was empty
right okay if you remember that they
attacked an empty military base to say
look what we did if you come after
soleimani right and then they said
we're not going to attack but the guy in
the iranian the military i think is a
foreign minister i don't know which one
it is
by the way can you type in around four
minutes that's a genius if you've never
seen this guy's interview you got this
is this is a strategist this is not a
lightweight guy
if you're talking let me see if it's if
it's uh go to images to see
go to images go to images yes
this guy's legit yeah this guy is a
a he is if you've ever seen any of his
interviews
he's not a lightweight okay he's not a
lightweight can i tell you something
about this yeah
who's my favorite guy on cnn that i was
like i love this guy i love this guy cnn
your
favorite zakari yes he does a show every
sunday
brainiac brainiac this guy comes on the
show quite often
an iranian foreign minister comes on the
if you did not know all the issues that
the united states has with iran
he is very convincing he's very
convincing very convincing he did an
interview on cnn he's very convincing
and he is very strategic so my my uh
my guess is the following if they do
attack
do you think trump is dead serious about
the counter attack to iran
yeah you ask me yes i do that i do do
you think he's that serious about how
ugly it's going to be for iran yes or no
frankly yes i do
do you do you do you say yes he is known
for his bluster however with iran i
think he's very
paying very close attention to them if
iran attacks a military base and one
soldier dies do you think trump will
retaliate i agree
do you think the exchange will be one
soldier for one soldier do you think
it's going to be a thousand seconds he
will make a point
perfect yeah i think they won't do
anything
until there's a different president
that's a little softer of course
and easier going to be able to make an
attack like that that's what i think
you're wrong yeah because look what did
what did iran do today uh jimmy carter
was no longer president what did they do
the day reagan
became a president what did they do what
did he back off i'm sure
they released the prisoners you remember
releasing the prisoners and reagan gave
the speech giving credit to carter and
same thing but what iran realizes
carter's not going to attack us how
about ben affleck did that yeah ben
affleck did that argo carter won't
attack
us but uh reagan will so you know there
is a part of uh
trump and reagan that they have some
similarities but where is iran on the
nuclear proliferation at this point
with everything that happened with the
iran nuclear deal and obama giving him a
boatload of cash and then trump pulling
out
and then they said that they're going to
start the nuclear proliferation again
where are they
they got this one country i don't know
if you've heard of called china that's
given them 400 billion dollars
and china just doubled their nuclear
uh uh powers that they had in china they
doubled it
not a little bit they doubled it they're
spending money into it and if they're
befriending north korea and they're
befriending iran it tells you who
china's allies allies are
and it also you know the new access of
you well and then the dynamic of the u.s
supporting saudi arabia
like we are you know troops financial
support
right there to keep iran in line so far
so good
yeah i uh um i i don't know i
i again i'd love to see nothing more
than to see iran be free again
and maybe i'll be doing some interviews
on that topic here pretty soon but let's
talk about
let's talk about singapore a new flight
that came out that's adam's type of
flight
okay singapore airlines came
out with a no destination flight meaning
a no destination flight to nowhere
can you pull that up guy so everybody
can see this thing so
these flights will take off and land at
the same destination
and will stay in air for around two
hours singapore airlines plan
comes after a survey by singapore air
charter showed 75 percent of 308
participants were willing to buy tickets
on these types of flights
according to the straits times report so
by the way this is not a joke this is
not an onion story
this is not a bumble what is that the
other way yeah this is
this is a real you know why they're
doing it why are they doing it they got
to keep their status
right they're like four thousand miles
short of keeping that gold status for
the next that's what it is
no i don't i don't think there's any
reason adam tell us your thoughts adam's
excited about this yeah exactly
so you get on the plane
you do the whole all right everyone
instructions you put on the seat belt
the face mask if it comes down
you take off you deal with the
turbulence you fly around in the sky for
a little bit
you land in three hours yeah there's one
reason you go on this flight why is that
you know you joined the mile high club
that's that's not what it is if i'm
if i'm with my girl and i'm like hey
baby we want to go on a little day trip
well i don't know we're on coven we got
lockdown what else we got going on mile
hike
who's do you disagree what if your
girlfriend said i'm already in the club
i've been on the club too but we got to
do this together so
those bathrooms unfortunately are very
small but that's
what are you gonna do sit there who's
going on this flight and being like yeah
i'll pay for the middle seat and i'll
just sit here i'll tell you what i've
been doing
singapore airlines good service i'm
telling you something's going on
so you're saying it's like a mile high
orgy going on
i don't know about all that but i'm
saying you're taking it to hold on this
is how bored people are these days is
they're gonna
get on the flight club for myself i mean
have you guys used singapore airlines
no have you it's the treatment is
another
really yes single airlines
by the way this is sam from columbia who
used to travel live with pablo escobar's
cousin
and uh he's been all over used to go to
singapore he used to go to singapore
there it is uh uh sheik j says spot on
soyboy yeah what's up jay with a
beautiful picture of himself no that's
trump yeah
you you've got a lot of things going on
so that's single point
i want to know how many people in the
audience by the way were at 2100 now
much respect to our
valuetainers on the pbd show how many
people out there are gonna get on a
flight
pay your couple hundred bucks fly around
in the air for three hours and just
return
back to where you started how many
people out there are getting on this
flight
please charge give a little uh feedback
uh what are they charging for this is
what they are
what's the wrong going rate 100 bucks
200 bucks 300 bucks
okay excellent by the way i have i have
a new um demographic for you to promote
your book to
flight attendants they have nothing to
do on planes right now in the us we
should make an ad for it just flight
attendants just fly all i do when i'm
flying back and forth from california is
you know you see the flight they don't
do anything
they're in the back of the plane reading
books that's all they do
are the flights still full when you come
in here or no kind of you know the weird
thing is
there's no business travelers and if
you've flown you know everybody knows
this you're just used to business
travelers right being 80
of a flight and it's zero percent of the
flight right now so it's a different
dynamic
the whole flying experience is a little
bit different right now but i have
noticed
that the flight effect attendants don't
have to do squat they do
nothing there's no service so they don't
have to do anything but they're reading
books
they're always in the back reading a
book well i think flight attendants
probably read more romance novels than
books like your next five books that's
what yeah but they might be
more 50 shades of grey type of a market
if you work for an airline what do you
want to be thinking of your next five
moves i think it's a good thing i mean
there's no question about it i fully
agree with you i'm getting a lot of nope
nope nope no one's flying
no one's flying no one's flying all
right so single one's going on this
guys if you're watching this you're
enjoying it press the thumbs up button
and subscribe to the channel and click
on the alert so you're notified the next
time we come out
with our following please
so uh uh again no one on this
channel has more nickname soyboy
followers
fans than you with your nickname soyboy
but let's talk about
warren buffett how about warren buffett
okay buffett campaigned
for obama and clinton but he hasn't
donated
or spoken out for biden and no one knows
why
buffett is now a long-time democrat the
ceo hosted a high dollar fundraiser for
president obama's re-election campaign
in 2011 served as his unofficial
economic advisor ahead of the 2016
uh election buffett spoke at a campaign
rally for her
secretary hillary clinton the wall
street journal floated the theory that
buffett's silence could be due to his
dislike of the virtual
event format favored by biden
campaign buffett's personal fortune has
declined 7.3 billion dollars in the past
your business insider previously
reported more in dollar terms than
anyone else on the forbes 100
of the richest americans so why is
buffett
not campaigning for obvious why is that
the guy is going broke man
it's tough he can't even afford yeah
he's struggling financially he's
struggling financially
he can't afford to even make an 18
donation he may be you know you know
what he's tough he's not maybe it's just
he lost seven billion dollars this year
i think
maybe it's so stressful that he needs to
go on a flight on singapore
hey i got another theory he's 90 year
old 90 years old maybe he doesn't know
there's an election
no i'm
i know he is i'm messing he's right
behind pat on the wall
any reason or no any reason or no
buffett's on the wall
that's milton friedman most people like
this bucket but it's got a way better
head
that's melted for capitalism
so but do you do you read into it at all
that's morgan freeman who is that
that's morgan freeman no that's that's
uh
mlk oh okay all right do you do you read
into it at all
at all like buffett is not campaigning i
think we're reaching here i know
you think so i think there is a point he
can't decide i mean usually i think we
are completely reaching right here i
think
i think this is a right i tell you what
i will tell you but i will tell you one
thing if you remember when buffett
went out there and campaigned a lot of
people during obama were like
wow if buffett is saying this
maybe we gotta just go for the
re-election it was very powerful when
buffett came out
because everybody sits there and looks
at the michael jordan investment during
our era to be who buffett so if the
richest guy who's an investor not the
richest guy in the world the richest
investor out there is supporting
a democratic candidate why can't i so
this whole
so i think it's a very strict i actually
think i actually think a buffett
endorsement
is worth more than ellen degeneres
than lebron james than any of the
celebrities all combined yeah
i think buffett is worth more of an
endorsement than all the hollywood left
celebrities combined okay
credibility i think so i think he's
conflicted realistically i really do
because
who's his best friend bill gates or one
of his really good friends bill gates
isn't going to waffle he's going to be
supporting a democrat maybe buffett
looks at the evidence he looks at the
tax plans and he knows the better choice
is to go with trump but he supported the
democrat candidate for so many years
he's friends with
bill gates and some of the others that
he can't come out and say anything
that's a possibility
i don't listen the guy has called for
higher taxes on himself i don't think he
necessarily cares i think we're reading
into this situation
i think and i'll go back to what i've
said before
you know why biden may win this election
you said 15 chance i'm giving it a 50
chance maybe
49 at this point it's not because people
are excited about bite
straight up nobody i know is like biden
bro
he's the man you got to see how he
sniffs women and how he falls asleep in
public you gotta check this
no this is a this is a either you're for
trump or you're against trump and the
reality is this 42 percent of the
country is for trump
46 percent of the country is against
trump four percent are voting for joe
jorgensen
and ten percent are still confused and
then they're not sure what they're doing
that's all this is so i like charles
fuchs said i'm moving to iran if biden
wins
good luck see let's talk about that
let's talk about that
going there obviously let's let's hope
that that guy's joking
but if he's not good luck in iran buddy
you really like defending as if he's
being serious you think that guys no but
but everything is so polarized but
listen man half of hollywood said if
trump gets elected
they're moving to canada they're still
in hollywood i mean it's like it's like
the biggest thing i swear to god if they
do this
right but there are a few that say i
swear to god if they do this i'm moving
out of the state of california or new
york
336 billion dollars of wealth left new
york and they never thought it was going
to happen
okay that's a lot of money to have left
so uh you know again
39.6 capital gains kramer was doing a
story yesterday i don't know if you saw
kramer yesterday so
seinfeld kramer no no no not uh jim
craver jim crane
is doing and he says well you know
there's a
uh some people are saying uh that uh uh
the
the biden tax plan is a little bit
aggressive and then he says
and he's trying to prevent himself from
saying it then in the middle of the
sentence just
it's chronically aggressive so he just
kind of goes meaning he couldn't even
well
he loses credibility because he can't
stand trump so he didn't want to say
anything
even he knows jim cramer cannot jim
cramer by the way data came back this is
from wall street journal
biden's budget to result uh can you type
this up type in wall street journal
biden's budget they have to see this
wall street journal biden's budget
there you go uh by the right right there
there you go look at that article
click on that one right there uh i hope
you can close the top
can you close it right there biden's
budget biden budget to result in highest
spending in decades that he finds his
proposal
would total 5. 5.4 trillion dollars
in new spending over the next 10 years
that's a lot of money 5.4 trillion
dollars of spending
wow over the next 10 years it's a lot of
money so that leads me to
what happened yesterday can you go up to
the tim kennedy tweet
with uh donald trump before we get into
the story
just type in tim kennedy trump here we
go
um but the one where he puts uh on my
podca okay right there
click on that one okay so tim kennedy
tweets out on my podcast with joe rogan
he offered to moderate a debate between
joe biden and donald trump
it would be four hours with the no live
audience just the two candidates cameras
and their vision of how to move this
country forward
who wants this he tweets this out it
gets 44 000 retweets
234 000 likes and donald trump
tweets retweets it and what does donald
trump say
donald trump says if you can go to his
twitter account go to donald trump's
twitter account
just uh all you have to do is click on
donald trump right there buddy
donald trump right there where it says
donald trump kai on the tweet it says
donald trump
okay go up we keep going up
keep going keep going up donald trump
retweets
and says i do meaning he would do it
keep going until you find it so the
viewers can see it
donald trump's as i would he's in for so
he's in so
four-hour debate between trump
and biden on the rogan show can you see
it
would biden agree to it would trump
agree to it
and if it did happen is that the
direction media is going towards biden
never his handlers would never let him
do that trump in a heartbeat would do it
i say do it as a pay-per-view
and then have bruce buffer involved and
then give the money to the winning side
i mean let's score this thing
treat it like a sporting event trump
would definitely do it that's his that's
his
that's his venue that that's where he
shines four hours he'd love that
i think he would love that so uh so kai
maybe just go on twitter
uh go on google and try to find it and
bring you back up while you're going
down the
pictures here so adam what would you say
to this rogan uh trump
biden debate on rogan with for four
hours yeah biden's you know still
has no clue who joe rogan is so he's
probably googling him right now and
being i don't even know this guy
but uh 90 i did a poll on my uh
social media on sas talks money and i
said would you want to see
this debate would you want to see this
most polls i do are you know 60 40 you
know yeah
this that sometimes they're 80 20. do
you know the results on this poll
take a guess 85 85 okay
90. everybody would want to see it 94
hell yeah
wow that was the options hell yeah or
maybe the people out there want to see
a debate yeah from joe rogan
with donald trump and sleepy joe biden
they want
that debate i'd like to hear our
audience weigh in on that would you want
to see joe rogan
host the debate between
the maga man donald trump what do you
think about sleepy jokes what do you
think about it
do you want to see it i think anything
that gets more
eyeballs on debates is a good thing
i think anything that makes
uninteresting
boring debates watchable and palatable
a good thing more people involved in
politics is a good thing
my first priority is good tv that would
be incredible tv
ratings watch that it'd be amazing it'd
be unbelievable
i mean look these these debates with the
same moderators anderson cooper
somebody from pbs you know
no one wants to see that everything's
packaged joe rogan would have them on
their heels just because
he's not is learned in the political
issues as much as some of these other
debate
uh moderators go onto youtube type in
joe rogan go on youtube type in joe
rogan
uh on youtube kai go to youtube first
we're getting a lot of hell yeah hell
yeah we really have to work on this it's
basic stuff
yes just type in joe rogan and then
solve filters at the top and go to views
our audience would love to see this
all right so watch if it's not done
right uh uh
go go it's coming up okay uh go
go to there you go perfect okay there we
go kai okay watches
joe rogan's most viewed podcast is with
elon musk
37 million views when he smoked that
most expensive i will tell you
if rogan is able to pull off trump and
biden
i'm telling you right now that's a 50
million plus
view debate that'll take place yeah and
that's why it'll never happen
it's exactly why it'll never happen
because
the part that we keep going back to
about these things
is the following when you're an agent
and you have a manager the manager's job
or the agent's job or the guy that's the
corner man
is to protect who the fire protected
the whoever it is the candidate right
how
how well does biden look on tv horrible
how does he do on tv he uh stutters
yeah he's bad he's pretty bad there's no
way in the world
his marketing manager is going to allow
this debate to be taking place and by
the way
trump tweeted it like this you haven't
heard anything from biden there's no way
biden would do it never not a million
years however here's a couple things to
be thinking about
number one how did politics transition
like go back 200 years ago when you read
about politics what were people doing
200 years ago to campaign debates they
would have open format debates lincoln
douglas the the famous debate the town
hall yeah town hall debates exactly then
big time newspapers then afternoon
then it was tv with kennedy nixon when
kennedy crushed nixon because nixon
didn't shave and he had a four o'clock
shave
maybe it's time to go into podcast
debates maybe it's time that american
people want to go like
yesterday i'm on the phone with one of
the top schools in south florida okay
i'm talking to this lady it's actually a
very good story
i'm talking to this lady and i'm asking
her questions she tells me about the
private schools about 30
30 or 30 35 000 per year per kid whether
it's kindergarten or senior by the way
and she says uh i said so tell me about
the philosophies of the school she says
what do you mean
i said faith-based how do you feel about
this she said well we're definitely not
a faith-based but we have a psychologist
on campus
that if your kids need to have some
issues and they're having challenging
times our psychologists are willing to
sit down and talk to your kids i'm like
great so psychologists are going to
teach my kids character that's okay no
problem
i said how does your school feel about
capitalism she says
you must be a trump supporter i said no
i'm a capitalism supporter i'm a
die-hard capitalism supporter
she says well what we do in our school
is we will teach socialism and we will
teach capitalism
and then we will let the kids decide
which one they think is better i said
wait what
she says yes i'm like okay
then she continues as she's explaining
all this other stuff she says
i said you know someone goes must be
american uh
it must be what must be uh oh that's
also a good school in florida by the way
so so then then i asked the question she
says
watch this then i asked the question
there's two schools that are hardcore
like that one is pinecrest one it's
american heritage
so then someone hit it on the nose did
someone hit it we're up to 2.2 keep that
thought
watch this though so then i asked the
question and i said
so what are your uh what are your
thoughts she says i have three kids
going over here so what do you think
about the schooling and the philosophies
in the school
she says uh i said because on your
instagram account your school just so
you know follows npr
follow cnn follows unicef follows the
world health organization follows
everybody on the left but it doesn't
follow anybody on the right she says
who says that i said your instagram
account so i go on their instagram
account and i show it to her
she says i can promise your owners don't
know this
i said what do you mean your owners
don't know this she says patrick i'm
telling you our owners
don't have a clue about this about the
fact that they by the way that's crazy
they just changed it all from yesterday
till today well that's activision okay
nice job so so she
said they changed it too anyway so i go
and i look at a lot of this stuff
so i said why is it i'm telling you we
probably didn't even know about this
that's our marketing department that
does this
so then she says to me she says patrick
says i don't watch fox
i don't watch cnn the only thing my
husband and i consume moving forward is
our podcast
we don't consume any news anymore it's
all podcasts i said who do you follow
then she gives me your names i follow
mark levine i said okay good
i follow staso i follow dan bongino dan
bongino is a stud you know who that
guy's
so she says but i don't follow any of
the podcasts anything
and then in the middle of it she snaps
she says oh my gosh
you're patrick bet david i swear to god
my husband and i follow your stuff
valuetainment she showed me the
subscribership
the point she made to me yesterday was
what
she said we don't watch tv we simply
listen to podcasts
because podcasts are easier way for me
to get the news how many more people in
america
no longer tune into the news and tv this
is why debate may need to be on podcast
and i hope it happens
pat i can support that statement so much
you know i considered myself
such a media savvy tv savvy individual i
worked in television for 15 years on the
news i thought that was the most
important thing i really did
and and whenever somebody said i don't
watch tv i thought they were idiots i
thought they were either lying or idiots
yep i i turn on no i've cut the cord
basically all right so i've got apps but
if i go to directv
i find that to be archaic i find that
technology to be so old
you know where you can't go past the
commercials or do things like that or
rewind or anything like that
i only watch the apps and get my news
and things like that so i think the
transition is real
is happening that's what obama won i
mean he he focused on
social media and then trump did the
exact same thing and beat hillary by
focusing on social media this is where
people are getting information is
podcast right now here's the other thing
about your story the scariest thing
about your story
was her admitting that they teach
socialism are you
kidding me i love the fact that she was
at least honestly crap
i can't believe because i always wonder
where do these kids that love bernie
sanders come from
i mean if you truly understand what
communism is all about
how are these kids that are supporting
him and so passionate about it
where do they come from but she just
said it they're being taught in schools
what socialism is
i'm actually surprised they're learning
one or the other i never learned about
capitalism or socialism
in high school is that even a is that
vienna in a civic maybe you weren't
paying attention maybe
maybe you need attention
i don't what class do they teach that is
economics government
i never took an economics class in high
school high school has economics 10th
grade i took economics in 10th grade
and and believe me i didn't do well but
i took it in 10th grade
in history better say hi to her she
might be listening yeah she might be
listening that's a good point but
but you know what the fact that she was
honest i said i said you know just the
fact that you're being that honest with
me i'm willing to come and take a tour
to school because i'm looking at like
seven eight schools
and that's one of the schools we're
looking at but i said look if if a
family's if you're going to public
school
i had this conversation the other day
upstairs with the 70 people that were
here
here's what i said to them i said
i said so many parents are not involved
in the day-to-day stuff with the kids
they're just not you let your kids go to
school and you have no control of what
the teacher's going to be teaching your
kids we keep talking about the stuff
right
so you got to be a little bit more
involved in what the school is teaching
if you are not teaching capitalism
i said what what programs do you guys
have for entrepreneurship
she starts smiling i said i don't know i
didn't i didn't tell a joke i'm actually
being dead serious
what programs you have about
entrepreneurship and then she shows me
we have an elective
i said i'm not spending thirty thirty
five thousand dollars you know what else
is crazy about that do the math i mean
you almost have to be a salesperson if
you're in that role of the
lady you were talking to yesterday
because you have two kids that's 35
times two
times what eight or ten that's a lot of
money compounded i mean how much you
would pay at school
i mean the wrong people the wrong
answers million bucks
is a seven figure mistake for that
school maybe more because you're
donating the same amount every year
you're kind of donating money as well to
the school if you're a booster hey you
do this you do that
so uh i don't know look it's just all i
can say is it's deeply concerning to
know that these schools that are private
schools
are not focused on teaching capitalism
and the people that can afford to pay
that kind of money are capitalists most
of all so
anyway so let's talk about what happened
in beverly hills kai you want to pull up
the video
so apparently beverly hills
has is a is becoming a hub for
conservative rallies go up a little bit
go up a little bit with the article to
read the main
point of the article how did beverly
hills become a hub for conservative
rallies
so they're going out there protesting in
beverly hills
90210 rodeo drive and this is what just
happened a couple days ago go down and
click on that video
there you go click on the video and you
can make it a little bigger
there you go make it bigger and hit the
audio so we can hear it kai
watch this listen to that this is
beverly hills
did you hear that
[Applause]
wow yeah that's you're talking about
beverly hills
one of the most expensive real estates
look at this
wanting to trash the american flag
dropping the american flag
oh they got weapons too
[Music]
where's taggart from beverly hills cop
when you need him you should've been in
there breaking that up
you know it makes sense that they're
doing those protests there because it's
you know you got the backdrop they're
doing it right on santa monica boulevard
right by the iconic you know fountains
and the beverly hills sign
and so you're going to get attention
you're going to get the cameras you're
going to get the the
dissecting opinion to it and it's going
to be like that every single week they
have these
every single sunday it's become part of
beverly hills you don't even go to
beverly hills anymore it's got to be
killing business
you know business is horrible to start
with in beverly hills but why would you
want to go down to a restaurant one of
the nice hotels or have brunch or
anything when that's going on
because it's going to be it's a melee
every single week down there
ladies and gentlemen welcome to joe
biden's america there it is right there
oh no hon we're still trump's still the
president right now that that's what's
okay
we're still in trump territory this is
scary my friend had this this is how
divided the country is right now is that
you can't even just go have a peaceful
rally we're gonna fist fight
because you want to show yourself can i
give a dark twist to this i'm gonna give
you a dark twist
dad the freddy krueger you had the
exercise let's give the well i'm gonna
give you a
crazy twist to this and tell me what you
think about this um
which side has more money republicans
are democrats
the party no no no the voters which side
has more money
well the democrats are more people so
volume they might
i'll i'll say republicans i'll take a
guess okay well maybe let me ask the
question a different way
okay which side's unemployment is higher
democrat left which side that's a trick
question
which side has more people unemployed
democrats or republicans
i don't know you really say i don't know
i don't know can you actually pull that
number up you actually say you don't
know
i don't know you say you don't know
which side has more democrats unemployed
okay uh which which side would like to
raise taxes and
tax the rich people obviously the left
or the right the left
the left okay which side historically
in the last few elections has
uh uh is willing to protest and riot and
loot and get pretty ugly about it
which side which side left or the right
both you're gonna say evenly i'll say
both sides right
no no you got to say which one's more
than the other the left
okay fair enough and this is coming from
somebody that is a liberal you're not a
left
you're liberal you're center left you
are you are not a moderate
moderate left no question about it i
will absolutely agree with that i'm with
you all
all my friends out there now he's
freaking socialist
bernie sanders you wouldn't have the
million dollars that you have if you
didn't have the money that you have
today if you if you were so
adam's a very independent worker he
comes in here not the first but he's the
last
that's we can say because he is in miami
time but but here's the part the part
that makes me think is the following
there are those that know how to lose
there are those that don't know how to
lose
okay what do i mean by this those who
know how to lose it's a very difficult
thing to learn to learn how to lose
when you lose you've got to go out there
and say i lost it's very annoying it's
public it's humiliating
no one likes it no matter who you are
it's painful
you have to go home to your kids you
have to go to go home to your wife to
your spouse
and all the haters that you were trying
to prove wrong
they're all going to come out it's their
opportunity i
told you so i knew he was going gonna
fail i knew he was a loser
you have to put up with that and that
noise is gonna last a few months until
the next time you go around in sports
you have one shot every 12 months
he doesn't have it lebron's you you ask
him give him a dollar and he asked for a
change he'll give you three quarters
back
right he won't give you four quarters
because he couldn't win back in the days
do you remember that remember that line
yeah okay so
until she came to the heat until they
came to the eats and then dwayne wade
bailed him out right so so so you go you
go
and you go and hear these stories and
then here's what you think about
when obama was a president how many
riots did you see
i don't know a lot of rights a lot of
rights why not if somebody was to ride
wouldn't be the opposition
how come we didn't have a lot of rights
record-breaking deport
i mean we had more people getting
deported than ever before you know
reagan
gave 3 million people amnesty obama said
he's going to give amnesty never
happened
so many mexicans and latinos love reagan
because they got amnesty from reagan
what happened with obama never got it
how come there was no protesting and
riots
do you think our country was as divisive
as it was now
no if not more you think it was more
divided in 2008
let me ask you a question how do you
know we're divided who's telling you
we're divided
i mean i'm just looking at what i see
but whose images the point is you think
it's divided because what the damn tv is
telling you that we are divided who the
hell is the tv
you're saying the media is hyping it up
of course if if you and i went out to
dinner
with 50 democrats 50 republicans
whoever it is with our friends we're
going to have a good time we're kidding
we're going to have a great time or you
go to a sporting event
in the stands i'm in chicago when i'm in
chicago i love going to chicago because
in chicago at a bar
i like going to a chicago bar at 11
o'clock 12 o'clock
you can have a drink have a great
conversation have debate about sports
because they love debating their sports
and they love debating politics and
you'll have the greatest debate he to
debate and you leave hugging a guy
yeah the bears in chicago you leave
hugging like oh my gosh john
you know i feel like i've known you for
years you give a hug and you leave screw
you
screw you up but the way the media is
painting it out
totally so dan so the reason why i'm
giving this point is because you said
something
you said america welcome to biden's
america
oh no it still trumps america they have
to paint
that during trump there's so much
division
that it's because of trump and people
buy it how come we didn't have this kind
of division on the
obama side because the media is
controlled on one side
and the right doesn't riot the way the
left rides
and that's a fact whether you're like
you know i'm i'm i've been a registered
independent for god knows how long now
and that's a fact to see that you don't
see that much
protesting rioting on the right nowhere
near as you see it on the right as you
see it on the left
so they have to paint the picture as
look what a terrible job trump is doing
today
and unfortunately that's going to work
with certain people
that's going to work with a few people
maybe that'll flip a few people
but come november 3rd i don't know
what's going to happen i don't think
this
strategy is going to be as effective as
they think it is in the streets of
beverly hills
this should be taking place crazy i
don't know about you you think it's 90
media a hundred percent media 50. i
don't think it's 90
media i don't think i don't think it's
100 media i do think it's 90
media okay yeah i think majority of it
is the media i think the majority of it
is somebody in someone's ears anytime i
had an employee that all of a sudden
turn against me like let's just say i
don't
tom and i i'm not in tom's year every
other minute
but somebody who doesn't like me
constantly calls tom
and bashes me behind closers on a call
to tom i don't know this
so tom talks to this guy for three hours
and i talk to tom for 15 minutes
if tom comes to me tom's influenced a
little bit whether he likes it or not
because tom's not on the pbd news
network he's on somebody else's news
network
i don't know if you understand what i
just said right there if if you're on
the call with somebody and you could
that's why i say the most important
appointment of the day is which
appointment
i've said this for the last 15 years the
first appointment or the last
appointment of the day last morning
most important part they always say
who's the last person in trump's ear
who's the last
important appointment of the day is the
last opponent of the day this is if you
don't win the wife you don't win the
person
it's the last appointment of the day so
i think the media unfortunately for most
american people is the last appointment
of the day and i'm going to say it's
more than 90
because you can say i'm not going to
watch the news and you can make that
conscious effort to tune it out
don't watch the shows at night don't
watch the newscast but you're getting it
everywhere 59.
right you're getting it from your vanity
fair updates your people magazine
updates your
daily show updates you're watching
comedians on the on the talk shows at
night on the commute
on the uh jimmy kimmel and jimmy fallon
and everything it's the same thing so
it's this subliminal message that just
pounds you all day long about how
divided we are well i got a conference
call right now 10 o'clock
no one came to warn me so we gotta tell
you we gotta wrap it up that's great
mario
i have all here by the way it's the
biggest podcast we've ever done it's the
biggest live we've ever had on this
channel folks it looks like you enjoyed
this one
appreciate you guys joining click that
click that thumbs up button subscribe to
the channel click to the alert button
by the way i don't know yet if i'm going
to be doing a podcast this thursday
because i may have some travel plans
but we will let you know come wednesday
if it is going to be going live and
you're subscribing to the channel
you will see it if not you won't see it
and we'll come back again next week but
either way
we had a blast with you today if you're
loving this format give us a subscribe
button give us an alert button
and put a thumbs up on the podcast today
gentlemen great job today we had a good
time this was great
thank you everybody bye bye bye bye guys
thank you
you